Саме такі мало би виглядати сортування непотребу.
А так воно зазвичай виглядає в реальності .
Все одно потім перемішається!
З нового року стане обов’язковим сортувати відходи.
Щороку в Україні утворюється, за даними Мінрегіонбуду,
близько 50 млн кубічних метрів побутових відходів.
Це об‘єм, що відповідає 20 пірамідам Хеопса.
Проблема України - у відсутності системи
поводження з відходами.
Сміття найчастіше просто спалюють,
а переробляють - лише кілька відсотків.
Тоді як мешканці ЄС, на відміну від українців,
вже давно сортують та переробляють.
Чемпіони у цьому - німці.
В ФРН теж відходи колись не мали жодної цінності
- їх теж переважно спалювали чи закопували.
Аж поки уряд не змусив підприємства робити
вторинну переробку сміття, а громадян - сортувати відходи.
В Євросоюзі за збір та утилізацію упаковки або небезпечних товарів
відповідають їхні виробники.
Частину коштів за це вони закладають у вартість своєї продукції.
Завдяки цьому в європейських країнах є контейнери
для різних типів сміття і пункти збору небезпечних
відходів та електронних приладів.
Натомість в Україні цього принципу
співвідповідальності виробника за утилізацію немає.
Вже зараз біля деяких українських багатоповерхівок
як у Києві, так і в регіонах, є контейнери для різних типів сміття.
Проте навіть якщо свідомі громадяни будуть
сортувати відходи, переробляти їх фактично ніде.
Сміттєсортувальні лінії в Україні вже працюють
лише в 17 населених пунктах,
це фактично крапля в морі.
Сміттєпереробних заводів - немає взагалі.
Будівництво такого планується розпочати у Львові 2018 року.
Одне таке підриємство коштує кількасот мільйонів євро,
будівництво триває кілька років.
У держави таких грошей немає, а інвестори
вкладати свої кошти не поспішають.
Україна не готова сортувати й переробляти
побутове сміття з 1 січня наступного року.
Адже зробити за кілька місяців те, на що потрібно
кілька років, неможливо, наголошують експерти.
Великі обсяги сміття в Україні, навіть розсортовані,
часто немає куди здати.
Оскільки натепер лише кілька відсотків населених
пунктів роздільно збирають сміття та
мають сміттєсортувальні лінії.
Вони ж мають бути у кожному обласному центрі та районах.
Аби їх облаштувати, потрібен час і гроші,
яких у держави немає.